ismaël il vient toujours avec vous sur
les tournages parce que je sais faire
l'avait allaité à un moment parce que
vous tourniez il est un petit délinquant
il peut m'accompagner il n'a pas encore
cinq ans il peut mal accompagné sur le
sur mon lieu de travail dormir avec moi
etc mais j'ai pas forcément envie qu'ils
soient sur le plateau j'avoue j'ai pas
envie qu'ils sachent ce que je fais vous
avez dit j'ai perdu mon insouciance mais
tous les jours je la redécouvre dans les
yeux d'ismaël voulu raconter la lèvre
maman le travail la caméra à jamais non
non vraiment j'ai pas du tout du tout du
tout envie qui j'ai pas envie que ça je
vais pas lui cacher toute sa vie mais ce
truc de représentation de comment les
gens se comportaient victoire et c'est
différemment de privilèges il va le
savoir et bientôt il va le découvrir
mais j'ai pas envie de qui soit sur un
tournage qui
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai je ne sais pas
je le ressens pas j'ai pas envie